alo alo Chào bạn
ở đấy Tao xóa này đi Ừ
xuống được à môi tôi sẽ phải sửa lại cái
mô tại đây lít ở trên YouTube
Vì sao tôi đẩy cái này tôi sửa sau
ở mấy cái câu trả lời này thì hôm nay sẽ
không không trả lời mấy câu này mà mình
sẽ trả lời mấy câu liên quan đến đồ án
nhá mày đồ án mà Thì
đầu tiên là
tên là
thì các bạn nào vẫn anh có ngại ý làm đồ
án Đoàn chuyên sâu này thì A vẫn có thể
đăng ký bằng inbox riêng của mình và
vừa rồi vừa có một bạn cũng nói chung là
nhiều bạn rất nhiều lúc và có kiểu có
việc bận đột xuất thì bạn ấy nhi
thỉnh thoảng của một bạn như thế lấy về
hiện tại đang có một bạn này là có ông
nào có nhã ý thì có thể inbox tôi thì
tôi cho Ghét luôn cùng với một ông à
anh tâm sự
tôi quên xương mất à Ờ ai đâu rồi ok
đề thi
ừ ừ
anh nói chung là hôm nay ở buổi đồ án
thì các bạn có thắc mắc thì gì
à
Hôm nay là buổi đồ án các bạn có thắc
mắc hay tâm sự giãi bầy
- cơ bình luận nhé
bước cuối cùng chuyển cho chuyên mục tâm
sự rồi cùng rất nhiều người on lúc đấy
chỉ nghe tâm sự à
sự phải biết điểm dừng này thì nó là như
thế nào đó là Ừ tôi đã từng nói với ông
về mấy cái vụ là mình phải biết mình
biết ta rồi
em biết địch biết ta nhưng ở đây không
biết địch biết mình biết ta tới làm gì
đó mình phải biết được mình thế mạnh là
gì ưu vào nhờ vào như nào và giới hạn
của khả năng của mình đến đâu cũng như
là cô nương đứng ở không đem cẩu bi quan
quá là kiểu khá nhiều người tôi thấy à
Chưa chưa bắt đầu làm cái gì đã đi qua
là mình không làm được không nên như thế
nhưng mà cũng phải biết được và năng lực
tối đa mình có thể làm được những đâu và
và đôi khi cố quá thì nó sẽ hiểu tốn
thời gian cũng như là nó sẽ làm cho mình
được chí rất nhiều cái nên là
Ừ Cái quan trọng là cái biết điểm dừng
này thì gọi chính xác là phải biết giới
hạn biết cái danh rồi nó là đến đâu đấy
rất là nhiều ví dụ Giả sử Giả sử nhé nó
ra Kiểu khi mà bạn à cố gắng học lập
trình này chẳng hạn bạn kiểu Giả sử ra
bạn không phù hợp với nó như là đến cái
ngưỡng nào để bạn biết được nó không phù
hợp
ông ngoại không phải là ngay từ đầu bạn
kiểu chưa học bạn đã kêu à Tôi không hợp
với nó thì nó nghe nó viện vào mắt nó
không nó đối với tôi đấy là con người
hơi bi quan
áo kiểu chú khỉ là mình phải tiếp xúc độ
lâu với nó thì mình mới đánh giá được
ngoãn chứ không thể làm à
Ừ vợ nhìn không ai khẳng định được một
cái gì cả đúng không ạ đương nhiên là ờ
có nhiều cái vừa nhìn mình không không
dám để mà thử rồi nhưng mà cũng có nhiều
cái mình nghĩ à
Anh phải thử nó mới biết được thực sự nó
như thế nào Thế bây giờ Rốt cuộc và phải
thử đến cái giai đoạn À thì mình mới
biết được là mình không hợp hay đúng ạ
Còn nếu có biết được mình hợp thì thì
chắc là tao kiểu ông ông thở dài Ông
thấy hợp thì không nói làm gì nó chẳng
có giai đoạn thì cái cả có người đến thử
tầm 12 tháng thì đã thấy hợp rồi có
người phải học một năm thì mới hợp nó
Vân đúng ạ
Ừ nhưng mà cái quan trọng ở đấy người ra
đạn nào thì chúng ta phải biết dừng lại
khi mà không thấy ổn cái gì đó
Mỹ Tâm Tự thể trong mối quan hệ luôn bây
giờ mối quan hệ của tôi
từ trước này một quan hệ tôi đều không
ổn nhưng hè cũng không biết Huyền với
ông đi làm nhưng mà Đúng là tội biết
điểm dừng đó là là tiểu à
cho tôi biết được không đến đoạn giai
đoạn nào là mình không cần phải cố nữa
mẹ hết khả năng rồi Nếu mà giả sử là đấy
giống như ta Tôi đã nói về vụ cái rồi
Giả sử tôi con trai thì cứ nhờ tôi kiểu
đi tán cũng các bạn nữ khác chả đúng
không Thì phải biết được đến giai đoạn
nào chúng ta không thể cố nữa cố nữa thì
nó cũng chẳng nho cũng chỉ thiệt thôi và
nó cũng không đem lại kết quả gì cả đấy
đúng ạ Nói chung là mình sẽ phải cân
nhắc nhở Cái vụ điểm dừng nếu mà xác
định được vụ điểm dừng đấy ông ạ
Ừ tôi thấy là mình mình có một cái một
trong những cái rất hay đó là mình có
thời gian mình có gọi là đế la à Kiểu
như thế Mình mình có kiểu mình có kiểu
dạng là
ở nhà mình không bất tử
anh đúng không ạ Mình có tuổi trẻ mịn sẽ
có về ra các thứ thứ mình có cái ngưỡng
ngưỡng nào đó hoặc để làm gì để mà mình
không Mình phải biết
mình phải biết cậu
ờ ờ gọi nhờ
khi dùng từ là
khi dùng từ đây có một cái tự nó về cái
thời gian phân bổ này ra nào Nói chung
phân bổ thời gian trong ngày hợp lý này
ai đây khi cài tiện ích tối đang cày để
mở kiểu cứ mỗi lần như này tôi sẽ ấn nút
này thì nhảy ra là năm gái
đúng lúc chuyển luôn đấy thôi tôi sẽ
quay lại nếu không có như không thấy gì
nhé nó thì ah
Ừ thì chúng ta sẽ phải biết phân bổ cân
đối thời gian trong cuộc sống ngoãn theo
tôi nên thế bởi vì a Ví dụ Giả sử
còn như giai đoạn mà ông kiểu dạng không
thể dành thời gian nhiều cho chuyện tình
cảm nhưng sẽ có những giai đoạn thì
không phải tập trung vào sự nhiệt và vân
phân bổ thời gian cuộc đời con người Nó
nói chỉ có thế thôi và kết hợp 24 giờ
mỗi người đều có 24 giờ không phải phân
bổ thời gian sao cho hợp lý không ạ Ông
không thể cả ngày mới làm việc tôi không
khuyên mày ông làm như thế
cô gái và cũng không thể càng ngày ngồi
chơi được như thế thì ông Đúng là thằng
Thành thằng ăn hại thật đấy ông ạ
Ừ tôi không nói mày Ông mấy ông cái thủ
chơi kiếm có tiền đâu nhé nhưng mà đại
khái thì mày không gửi rồi mà không ạ em
chưa mình nhá
mày là phân bổ thời gian ông ạ
phiên bản tiếp theo tôi một lần nữa Nói
chung là thỉnh thoảng tôi sẽ quen một tí
về nghề nghiệp tôi vì thế sản là mấy ông
ở đây đa số là đến đến cái do à này thì
anh nói cho đến buổi mày ngồi nghe Chắc
là mấy ông vẫn đang theo ngành này chúng
tôi rồi em ấy ông đã mông lung mà ngoài
này họ ông ấy cho vui thì tôi lại một
lần nữa nói về việc là cái ngành của
mình thì công nhận là thoải mái theo
kiểu là Đấy Hiện tại thì
ở hiện tại thì
tôi Ví dụ đặc biệt ở Hà Nội đang rất là
mưa à rất là nắng hạ Thôi vậy Mấy tuần
trước nó sẽ làm ư ạ Tôi chỉ việc ngồi ở
nhà cậu không cần phải lên công ty ra nó
cũng sẽ dẫn đến những cái hậu quả về sau
Nhưng mà chắc là anh em mình chụp đến
tầm 5 30 thôi rồi giải tán làm mới khác
kiếm tiền để làm cái khác như Còn trước
mắt thì anh em mình thoải mãi ngồi nhà
làm được và làm lúc nào cũng được nó
không bị gò bó thời gian lắm
A và Chắc là ở công ty tôi mới có kiểu
được như thế và một vài con ty nữa thôi
chứ còn đa số công ty vẫn có kiểu khái
niệm mà phải lên công ty phải chấm công
có thể nhớ là Vân
Ông này ông kia có bạn đến like nữa ở
công ty tôi thoáng lắm rồi chẳng có
deride gì đây cả À
ừ ừ
vấn đề cần phải làm nhanh nằm làm phải
làm gấp mấy cái bất cần tích gấp Ngư
Ngoài ra thì có những tính năng thì nó
sẽ mình cứ kiểu linh hoạt Thời gian làm
làm thoải mái
phải sắp xếp thời gian để làm đúng không
ạ
tôi tôi đã nói chung là tôi thường ra
gần đây tôi bận rộn thật nhưng mà tôi
cũng sắp xếp thời gian để làm việc vẫn
hoàn chỉnh kê gà Mấy ông không hiểu tôi
vừa rồi tôi đi du lịch đúng không Tôi
vẫn mang laptop đi mà đề phòng có vấn đề
gì đó thì còn sửa luôn chứ không phải là
mình bị bị bị động quá nóng ạ nhưng phải
chủ động
có tình huống như mình phải xử lý được
luôn
Một lần nữa lại nói về công việc này nó
khá là ốm tôi cảm thấy đến bây giờ vẫn
ổn sau nhiều ngành nghề khác
Ừ ông cứ thử ở kỳ thời tiết Hà Nội hiện
tại đi Trưa nay tôi vừa ra ngoài làm
kinh khủng xinh nhất ở ngoài vào trong
khi đó mình ngồi làm việc mình trong
điều hòa mình ngồi làm tại nhà vừa Vân
Đấy đúng ạ và và mình kiểu nói chung là
mình cứ nghĩ cách giải quyết có hướng
tiền tươi về
về cơ bản tôi sẽ thoải mái mà
có ai lấy tôi còn đang tôi còn vừa đặt
mua à ngoài đặt mua tôi với mua cái máy
á phun sương Anh Vinh show anh ấy giới
thiệu là nó tầm 500k Tôi sẽ thử phun
sương của xíu nhi Tôi sẽ thử xem phụ
full nó có mát mẻ hơn nữa thứ không
Trước mắt thì chắc là mát mẻ hơn tí vào
thứ hai là là nó tăng độ ông
Uh cho nó đỡ kiểu khó chịu trong ngày
nắng nóng này cũng nghĩ thế
à à
Ừ có gì đâu mà giàu 500.000 rồi dùng dầu
à tới mua toàn mấy máy chục triệu
Ừ đúng một triệu chục triệu đấy cậu máy
lọc không khí ạ
hệ thế nên à
ờ ờ thế nên là kiểu tôi mới nói ngành
này thì K phù hợp với tôi ý nghĩa là với
tôi Vì tôi
tiêu phá kinh khủng màu vàng mày gạo
Ngày ngày nó càng được ngành khác không
chuyện đấy
một ngày khác thì tôi phải làm sếp thì
mình kiếm được mà dẫn ra ngày khác thì
tôi phải làm hộp bơ rồi ngày ngày người
ông thấy ngày tôi vẫn nhiều làm kiểu nho
lợi ích này sướng ấy nhỉ mô phỏng giao
diện chiều cái này tôi thử à
Cho tôi xin phép Bây giờ tôi sẽ tả lại
một loại hết
à à
Đợi thì đợi tí nha
khi sex
xe côn tay được quá nhỉ
ở khu
à à
ô ồ nó bớt hết thấp biết tính hết rồi
chị sẽ bị
à
Bạn biết về level và pp chưa
Ừ nếu mà bạn có biết về pp và Vario rồi
thì bạn thể đăng thì inbox riêng qua
mình qua discord hay Facebook hay à Nói
chung mà inbox mình qua mấy lần tàn ở đó
thì mới có nhóm đang đẻ này thì mình sẽ
cho bạn vào một nhóm
anh em mình sẽ làm thì bạn kia sẽ chỉ
cho bạn
à Còn nếu mà bạn chưa biết pp thì bạn
học khóa cơ bản của mình như thế bạn
chuyển qua học khóa cơ bản lập trình web
của mình để biết nhé
Bây giờ tôi sẽ chấm từng nhóm có vẻ và
nhóm cập nhật rồi có phải nhóm chọn
triển các bạn xem chỉ cần tôi rồi
Ừ ừ thế chăng
phím tắt là gì nha à
là gì
Ừ tí Đợi tí nha
sao histidine
nó hơi bị xóa xu hướng tóc rồi
I for Selection cần dùng chiếc xe
em không nhớ số tôi bị bắt rồi
anh đã bị xóa luôn đấy hôm sau à
ở Kon Tum ship hát
à à
em ở trong nhà
từ tài liệu
à
à à
ở những cây chấm vs Cốt đã thấy không
tín thôi đậu xanh
Ừ cái này ông mày nhóm 2
Ở nhóm 2 rửa xe máy nhóm hay như nào nhé
đợi được yêu thích
ở nhóm hài
kể từ tháng 7 tháng 5 có làm gì alo
Chúng tôi sẽ liên hệ nhóm 2 sau
À hôm nay buổi tâm sự mà Mấy ông có gì
cứ tâm sự nhé để nó cho hôm nay buổi thư
giãn là chủ yếu người ông thể ngồi xem
tôi chấm và góp ý các nhóm khác và có
thể chửi nhau mâm nữa Vân mặc rất nhiều
cái
I Have they đây tôi hôm trước tôi khuyên
rồi mày Ông đừng có để kiểu kiểu đặt tên
là update ngay người khác nhìn chẳng
hiểu ông con biết cái gì cả
thôi tôi cứ chấm lần lượt từ đầu đi thôi
quên mất là hôm nay tôi không chỉ chấm
mỗi về cái á
mỗi người mỗi cái này nó Tôi sẽ chấm hết
là từ đầu đến cuối ông đã làm được những
việc gì nó sẽ ghi ở trong cái này Vậy
xóa đi này tôi sẽ ghi hết vào trong này
là là bạn đấy đã làm những cái gì thì nó
sẽ hợp lý hơn bỏ qua vụ chấm chấm về cái
á
em
về mấy cái kia đi vậy
à à
à quên quên hôm nay là mình phải đánh
giá tuổi đánh dám cách trồng quan là
nhóm đấy đã làm những cái gì con thiếu
cái gì thì nhóm đấy phải tự biết dựa
theo thì trước tiêu chí đi rồi
với lại xem một cái con nít bất kỳ với
tôi không thể chạy cốt được tất cả của
tất cả đúng không ạ thì tôi sẽ xem à Một
cái file bất kỳ xem bạn để chốt như nào
là sửa chứ Xem tất cả các nhau một chỗ
chạy thử tất cả nhóm thì
chị thôi điên Gọi điện mẹ 500 thời gian
làm hết rồi Cả lúc đấy được thì đây
các bạn mới chỉ làm sạch đờm ization
chẳng có gì mấy
10 người có bạn chẳng có gì à sẽ Chị đâu
rồi Nóng malaysian
I love into your bài 15 view tôi không
không yêu cầu các bạn làm với view làm
ra nó chẳng có cái gì đấy cả không có
tài liệu thì tài liệu thì tài liệu là
mấy ông sẽ bổ sung liên tục Tôi sẽ không
ngồi chấm lên tục tài liệu mấy ông được
Tôi không điên như thế này ông sẽ tự bổ
sung liên tục tài liệu mấy ông này mấy
ông hoàn chỉnh đến cuối thôi mày 10 xét
duyệt tài liệu của mấy ông này không
hiểu chứ tôi sẽ không phải ngồi liên tục
chấm tài liệu của mày không được ngoạn
à à
khi phân tích
hỏi chị ngồi Cập nhật cái phải phân tích
chưa
à à
họ đậu xanh chẳng có cái gì cả
sữa súng có
Ở đây có Index rồi
em
có luôn đặt tên như này như tôi bảo thì
không nên đặt tên kiểu nhà phải khai rõ
ra là ví dụ là đây thêm một level không
ạ thì sẽ sẽ là tên là app con lum level
in two in tui Đi chùa mà tôi sẽ đặt tên
là Enter Ăn tơ rồi mới áp có lum
tu-lu-dơ Thay bồ cho nó kiểu nghe phải
rõ dễ hiểu xong rồi Tiếp theo là tôi sẽ
phải kiểm tra xem mà cái cột đấy tồn tại
không thì tôi mới mới thêm nó và cột này
nên after after cái gì và đế for là cái
gì Tại sao phải như thế là vì
Ừ ông làm như này thì có thể nó sẽ lỗi
khi mà dữ liệu mà có sẵn rồi đúng ạ vậy
Rõ ràng là ông ông thêm một cột vào
trong cái bảng mà có có dữ liệu rồi mà
không ở đây fo nó mà không cho nó nun
luôn ai bồ nữa không được phép để chống
nữa thì chắc nó có thể báo lỗi
mai trong trường hợp bị trơn này thì mặc
định nó sẽ không là em đừng ngoạn Và nếu
mà sẽ truy nhìn mặc định chỗ chỗ trống
nhưng mà nhưng mà nhiều lúc nó sẽ báo
lỗi nhé Thế mày không sẽ phải nên cho nó
free force và nên nó vẽ actor cái gì đó
Đấy lại tôi Thỉnh thoảng Tao chữa cho
mấy ông sẽ kiểu sẽ khuyên mấy ông lại
mấy vụ đấy nhưng mà rõ ràng tôi cố trong
cốt khi cốt đoán thì mấy ông thấy cách
tôi cốt myrosin rồi mà nóng hoặc tối có
làm rồi mà
Mấy ông phải xem cái anh nói chung là
tôi cốt thì nó vẫn theo phong cách cả
Kiều
Thế Âm Nhạc cũng hơi khó để cho người
mới học nhưng mà
cho tôi tôi làm theo phong cách cốc đến
đâu chuyển đến đấy chứ không phải giống
như hồi trước à là làm từng bước từng
bước xong rồi mới hôm sau làm từng bước
từng bước nữa nên là nên làm thực ra
những cái đấy thì mấy ông cũng nên học
hỏi luôn là đồng nghĩa việc của béo hơn
nhảy cóc một tí những đồ ăn này đồ ăn
phải phải cầu lô xác nó đúng như thế em
bé không phải cậu phải giỏi giọt lên một
cách nhanh hơn cho bình thường bởi vì
học tập lập trình nói hẳn ra học lập
trình chỉ trong vòng 4 năm tháng thì nó
vẫn rất là kiểu
thì nó sẽ rất là nhanh mà đúng không ạ
Ừ thế anh anh nhá học 4 năm tháng ông có
thể đi làm thì ông kêu rồi chun eo các
thứ thì chắc chắn ở lúc phải quá đỉnh
luôn bởi vì vừa học của các hợp với cả
làm thực tế luôn mà không ạ nên thành ra
nó mấy ông đương nhiên mấy ông thể xem
đi Xem lại video cho hiểu tôi không yêu
cầu mấy ông muốn nghe phát hiện ngay
nhưng mà nói chung à tôi dậy cho bé ông
một phát là chuẩn luật chứ mấy ông đỡ
phải thiểu
đỡ phải kiểu dặm là kiểu
phải hôm nay học buổi này xong rồi xong
rồi buổi hôm sau lại nâng cao hơn tí Vân
không Thỉnh thoảng tôi mới làm thế thôi
còn không thì tôi dậy một phát thường ai
chuẩn luôn
khi sex
dạy khóa làm việc nhóm với ít sắp đi nó
em làm việc chung cốt thì cứ nộp tung
lên
ờ ờ
Ừ cái này thì giống như là ở
rất khó để mà tránh Conflict Nếu mà giả
sử các bạn cùng đẩy lên cùng một cái một
cái Zippo đặc biệt là
chính sang một cái friend Nếu mà do sự
là là
quen đấy còn là quen kiểu Master nữa
đúng không ạ Nếu không nên tạo quen
riêng rồi mấy ông đẩy lên để em quen của
bản thân mình thôi Khi mà đang có giờ
đến đâu đẩy lên quen lên đấy Nói chung
là ok ông nhá thời để bồi âm sau tôi sẽ
của Mai buổi chữa này không hẳn là tôi
nói về huyết áp này lắm sẽ để tạm đây
nhá ạ
em cách post code
vì lý tưởng để cách tôi tôi Thực ra tôi
không trứng vịt cho làm để mở thể chỉ
với ông Bởi tôi nói rồi đó là bây giờ
tôi mới chính thức đi làm tối mới động
vào get còn hồi trước thì tôi không dùng
ít tôi chờ ở dạng kiểu à Làm cá nhân mà
lưu sẵn cốt để trên máy cũng cần phải để
đi đâu đâu nên hãy ra là kiểu
cũng không phải quan tâm mấy cái gì lắm
nhưng nhưng mà bị bây giờ thì tôi là một
công ty thôi à Cái phong cách đẩy ghi ở
trên công ty thôi Nó hơi khác còn bây
giờ mấy ông làm theo nhóm mình Hai người
cũng có thể hơi khác nữa không ạ
ừ anh hãy ra là tôi tôi hôm sau tôi sẽ
chỉ theo kế cái cách nghĩ của tôi hoặc
là mấy ông cũng thể hôm sau mình sẽ bàn
với vụ đấy mình sẽ bà được vui vụ đấy
thì chả có thể tôi sẽ đây Bây giờ tôi sẽ
tạo thật buồn Ở trên này trên trên này
nhé
a foodcourt hồng ngoại
xe buýt
ờ ờ
à Cậu dạng là cứ cho là dưới mấy người
đi
à mà không có biểu tượng đi dưới đây à
ở những ơi chẳng hạn lên như nào
thì các bạn
em suy nghĩ và ý kiến ở đây à à
Ừ anh nhóm này vừa là gì nhỉ nó này là
anh cũng làm một cái cứng đối số đây rồi
Ừ ok
Ừ rồi Ờ
không lên này file thì nó nên viết hoa
từng chữ cái đầu một nó store A và như
này với sông sẽ tạo rất nhiều rất nhiều
cái vi quét nên cách đặt của tôi lần
trước tao đặt đó tên thư mục sau đó thì
tên của ví dụ thật sự là tất and tendon
xong rồi đấy thôi mục attendance sau đó
thì kẹo khoai nữa là file kiểu Story
quét Hãy im đấy quét gì đó nó sẽ rất dễ
hiểu Tuy tạo rất nhiều thư mục Nhưng mà
như thế nó sẽ rõ ràng hơn chứ không phải
đặt tên cầm nha sẽ vừa bị dài nó kết hợp
được à sau mình nhìn trong đấy ông nhìn
có đọc được mấy ông ạ trong thư một ngày
bị nhiều quá không ạ Mình chưa nhỏ ra
theo thư mục đỡ hơn Ê hồi hướng em là
tên là tại sao phải đừng để không biết
hoài à
Anh quay vệ sửa cách sửa tay nó
anh Trung à à ta bay và có một tí CRD
không ạ
ừ ừ
em có cả cái Tôi muốn trang xuân ở đây
này
à Còn tao đây thôi
Âm Nhạc
khi đăng nhập vào Hữu thử vẫn cần điều
trị mụn Doctor bai
ừ ừ
ý gì vậy
ta có
những bài rap nữa
đ.d Brom
35 Để xem mạng năm
cũng cập nhật luôn ạ chẳng có cái gì
trong ngày đậu xanh
à à
nếu mất tích hết à
nó ra cái này ở trên Hưng tinh thần tự
nguyện đây là tôi không có không gì đến
like liên tục mấy ông kia anh không muốn
á nhon
chấm hết chứ kiểu này không hiểu rồi chị
ạ đâu không để
Ừ tao không kiểm tra mày ông kiểu này
giàu quá dở quá
ờ ờ
nhóm 5 tại chưa có cái gì cả Ở nhóm 6
nói ra
a friend
phương pháp mô phỏng tính năng
Ừ chị lái xe Đợi tí đâu có mình không
một phòng tính năng đây
U17 làm chị nghỉ trong được
đi xe máy sạch Love
à à
Ừ nhưng mà bị thừa thiệu thuộc cách ở
đây nó hơi ngứa mắt nhỉ
chị đánh kiểu kiểu đặt tên nhà hả hai
hôm trước tôi bảo với kiểu Vy như này
thì ông sẽ kiểu sẽ sẽ sẽ kiểu dạng mà nó
sắp xếp theo đúng thứ tự 1 2 3 ngôn ngữ
lại
con gà về cái vụ chỗ trống từ trước nay
tôi không hề thích cái vụ xử trống lắm
ảnh bìa
cho Mắm bấm mà xem mà biết được là còn
còn chỗ ấy con thôi Còn nếu sổ trong cửa
ngày nóng Star nó thằng bên đối thủ
người ta mà uống hết sự chỗ đấy Nên là
thành nó không lên kiểu này
ông còn làm cái vụ là kiểm tra chắc chắn
đó thương nữa
à à
số chi tiết giáo viên
khi
một loạt trên mạng xã hội trại dưới làm
gì à
cách trị nám
Ê mày cái ai trông em xin lỗi
xem danh sách giáo viên
em vẽ tín ngoạn hướng lên ra ngoài biên
hòa đã
ôm sao
an Đăng ký tài khoản à
anh
không Không có vụ đăng ký tài khoản đó
đăng ký tài khoản để gì nhỉ
kỷ niệm biến Đăng ký lớp học à
ok ok ok
à à
học nó sẽ nhảy sang cái tra Đăng kịp
đăng ký rồi chứ không có xem đăng kí tài
khoản là tách biệt ngay đâu nhưng nhóm
này bị nhầm đấy
đến xem mà ví dụ Giả sử là
em giả sử là bây giờ Tôi muốn đăng ký
một cái lớp học nào đó tôi chỉ cần để
lại đúng đi Mail là số điện thoại rồi
người ta sẽ chủ động liên hệ với mình
sau đó thì sẽ cập nhật thông tin của sẽ
hỏi thêm mình và thông tin nữa để mà để
mà tạo bằng thì lấp cho mình không cần
phải đăng ký tài khoản không cần nhiều
thông tin như thế này
xem được học à Để đăng ký lớp học hình
như tôi vừa nói là có việc bỏ qua đúng
không Nhưng mà để xem được học để xem
nhé Đi học vui trực ta có thể gửi qua
Email có lịch học cũng được vào đăng ký
tài khoản có lịch học mẹ tạm thời đi làm
như thế rồi chi tiết lớp học sẽ à
em xem lịch học đấy đúng không Ok chi
tiết Lịch học
Việt
Ừ đấy lỡ đang ở đây có nhân viên tư vấn
và đúng không có nhân viên tư vấn thì nó
phải duyệt cái tài khoản của ông Lúc
đăng ký này bởi vì cái lúc đăng ký này
ông đã phải có
Ừ ông à đây đây đây tên tư vấn viên á
Không chọn này sai rồi này đấy tôi biết
mà ông này bị hiểu nhầm rồi rõ ràng khi
đăng ký lớp học thì thì phải là tất cả
quay lại cái bên chi tiết lớp học này
này họ sẽ hiển thị ra cái cái đăng ký ở
đây này ấn vào đăng ký thế thôi sau đó
sẽ có tư vấn viên sẽ gọi điện Hà làm
kiểu gì liên lạc được với ông qua email
của ông chẳng hạn ngày qua đừng Linh gì
giờ Nói chung Aqua số điện thoại nạn
người gọi liên hệ với ông Sau đó thì
sẽ thêm học viên vào trong lớp chữa ông
không phải là kiểu hiển thị ra kiểm ngư
hay chị bảo nhân viên đấy cũng sẽ khẩu
tự động
ông có thể điền cao lúc máu Nguyễn Đăng
ký mà nhân viên lấy gọi xác thực lại
những thông tin thì thôi
chat nữa không chắc trùng đấy cả chút
tạp không bỏ qua vụ trùng đi lưu ý Thông
tin nhiều lắm à
để xem danh sách sinh viên à
hạn chế đó nhá Nó không nên xem những
cái thông tin nhạy cảm người khác
anh
bị nhảy sang hiện nay cũng được bài dân
mới công làm về thấy bồ nhưng mà nó làm
có chỗ khác kể
rồi tôi sẽ chỉnh sửa qua thôi tôi không
đủ ra nó chữa chi tiết được ok nhóm này
có vẻ này ô ồ tạm ổn rồi Xong rồi thì
đến tỉnh nào các bạn thấy inbox riêng
tôi để chữa cụ thể tính năng đấy sau và
bệnh không đi về sau sẽ có những buổi
gọi là demo thử những cái năng tính năng
kiểu có những có những cái tính năng
có nghĩa sẽ hẹn buổi Thứ bảy này ngoài
việc với sao tôi chưa chấm chữa cửa này
thì sẽ cần một vài nhóm để mô cái tính
năng mà họ đang là ví dụ Giả sử bây giờ
là cái cho Bây giờ là giữa tháng 6 đúng
không ạ mình đặt tự bật đến like đi đúng
không ạ bây giờ là
Ừ thứ bảy này đến cuối tháng 7 đi cuối
tháng 7 các bạn Chốt rồi nhá cuối tháng
7 mình sẽ có một cái deadlines đó là tất
cả mấy ông sẽ phải để mô
chị sẽ để mù bắt đầu từ từ ngày 30 này
cho đến tuần sau nữa ra xử rạp sự thế
Xem có nhiều nhóm để mua được không để
mua là mình đang làm đang làm những cái
tính năng gì rồi để mà các nhóm khác
nhìn vào nhau góp ý cũng như học hỏi
cũng không sao cả chúng ta làm ở đây với
tinh chức tinh thần họ chứ không phải sợ
bị ăn cắp ý tưởng cái gì cả nó không Sợ
hấp dẫn ăn cắp cốt ở đây chúng ta sẽ học
trò đối ngoại để mà để mà cùng cùng cùng
rút kinh nghiệm cũng như là kiểu đấy thì
thì các bạn cũng sẽ
thì các bạn cũng sẽ phải cẩu chủ động
hơn Chứ bây giờ không có một cái mép
like gì cả mấy ông cứ làm thì làm xong
rồi mấy ông tự ngồi ngắm tự khen hay thì
làm sao tiến bộ được không ạ Đấy thì
chắc chắn phải có cái đây like đó hả Đi
like thì lấy 30 thằng 30 tháng 30 tháng
7 cơ mà 30 tháng 7 cho đến
Ừ cứ cho hai tuần đi vào mùng 6 tháng 8
nữa thoải mái đi bởi vì mình cũng Mình
cũng định là đến tháng 9 còn nhiều mình
sẽ bảo vệ xong hết Mà cái tầm Cứ cho là
tầm
ở dưới tháng 8 mình phải Diệp vài lần
đấy vài lần trước khi mà đến tháng 9 là
mình chốt Làm sao biết đấy Nấu hiểu mà
khi bé bà làm gì cũng nhập Đấy Bây giờ
mới có tháng 6 thôi nhưng mà tháng 7 rồi
ông ngồi họp Ơ làm để cuối tháng 7 Để mô
không ạ Anh xong rồi Thắng
ở đây mua được đến đâu để mua nhá Không
không phải để mua hai cái và bảo vệ Loan
cuối mà để mua đường đến đâu đấy mô để
mà có gì tôi còn góp ý liên tục được
không ạ Đấy bình thường ở ở trên lớp của
tôi là tuần nào cũng phải
cuối tuần não phải để mô cơ đấy
em đi rồi Còn một tháng thì cho ông bây
giờ hơn 1 tháng tháng rưỡi thì cho mày
ông bắt đầu bây giờ bắt đầu làm còn kịp
mà có gì đâu không
ở trung tâm mà trong tháng 9 này là sẽ
bảo vệ liên tục luôn này bảo vệ bảo vệ
và để thử liên tục để chốt cho mấy ông
bởi tháng 10 có bay rồi mưa rồi bay Sài
Gòn ạ Lúc đấy tổng khá như việc nữa nha
cho tôi không thường xuyên để mã dậy
cũng như chậm Nhưng bé ông nữa
đúng rồi Bây giờ Bây giờ sáng em với ông
phải chuẩn ra là bây giờ tuần thứ tư
tuần thứ Năm rồi Để tuần thứ 5 Đấy thế
là mấy ông đã phải làm được một cái gì
đó cậu nói chung là xong về cái cơ bản
về cái nền rồi để cho nó bây giờ mày
xong cái lên rồi đúng không ạ Đấy bây
giờ một tháng rưỡi nữa thì ông chỉ cắm
đầu vào ngồi cốt làm xem thêm sửa xóa
cái tính năng gì gió với Vân không ạ sau
đó thì những cái tính năng khó thì ông
sẽ mất tầm 23 tuần cho một cái tính năng
khó đúng không ạ Chị sẽ sẵn à là khi mà
đến tháng 9 rồi là con ngựa ông ở gần
như xong gần như toàn bộ thì năng cũng
tương đối hoàn chỉnh được một cái mua
cái phần mềm đầu vào đồ ra có vẻ ổn rồi
chẳng qua là
vì nó có thể chưa có thể có nhiều tính
năng thôi nhưng tính năng nào phải ổn
phải kiểu xịn rồi ông ạ
Anh trông định để lấy like đến bao giờ
ở thành phố cái đồ A nó đang tận 4 tháng
cả ngồi đấy tôi làm đồ ăn chị 22 tháng
rưỡi rồi bây giờ là rõ ràng là tôi bắt
đầu từ đầu tháng 5 mà bây giờ là giữa
tháng 6 rồi nếu không bị đi lấy thế thì
cứ đầu năm đến tận cuối tháng 9 ở bụng
45 tháng gì đấy
được đâu đấy hả phải làm
á nhon
rồi
em biết ở đây không biết
Ê mày chỉ có mỗi Tài liệu ngoài nhà mày
không có tài liệu cũng chưa có ra tao
bây cũng chưa có đúng nhỉ Tao bây đâu
đấy Nhìn cái có mít trong cũng phải xịn
họ
cũng cũng được đấy chứ 8:02 bắt đầu ngồi
con nít một đoạn lên
anh được
ông Nguyễn Minh Châu Á
Ừ
rồi không biết rồi tên mày Nam hay nữa ờ
xem nha
anh không cần này nhắc lại cái tên không
cần nhắc lại Tên này ở trong này cũng
được
a cho tôi khó hơi khó chịu với quả mà
cậu Long Biên Hòa lúc không ngay không ạ
kết hợp với thiếu dấu cách ở đây
em ở chỗ một cách đặt tên nhóm vừa nãy
vẫn hay hơn một nhanh hay rồi một việc
nhanh video hoặc 12 luôn được về trong
đấy làm gì có thêm người nữa mà 122 giờ
đây không ạ
ô tô cách tạo xe biển số xe loại xe sơ
đồ ghế
sẽ có số đo ghép ở đây tôi nhớ là tôi bỏ
qua vụ sau ghế mà
Ồ vãi cả chưởng sơ đồ ghế của ông Đức à
anh như thế này à
đâuchữa kiểu này đâu nhỉ khái niệm suốt
ghế đây nhỉ Anh xài nhé bây giờ
à Chị nhập số lượng ghế rồi nhỉ
là
cô gái thường để biết được sao
Ừ thôi cứ gửi thường thôi không ạ Đoạn
này đoạn này lại phức tạp hóa vấn đề dạo
này làm cái ghế thừa cái vip chẳng đi
đến đâu phải thường mà chẳng có xe đưa
nha Có xe con sẽ hiểu Có sẽ kiểu ghế
dừng 52 Cá thứ nhưng mà nó không phải sơ
đồ ghế kiểu như này
thì nó sẽ ra rồi nếu mà ông đặt Thế thì
ông sẽ phải là
a tiếp thẳng luôn cho
Cho tôi xem phim Dung nhá ờ ờ có thể có
nhiều xe cũng cùng chung một cái sơ đồ
đúng không cùng chung một cái loại loại
ghế không ạ
Ô thế mình sẽ cập nhật số lượng vào đây
nói kiểu khác là kiểu không phải tên đâu
Nói chung là nó chọn là
cậu nó sẽ là ông dạy chọn loại
đây tôi thử vẽ cho mấy mấy ông dễ hình
dung nhé FPT cho nhanh nhé
Ừ hai cái kia
thế kia nhiều Tôi phía phải
cho xem
u80 làm kiểu này nhé kiểu này người dùng
chẳng hiểu của ông đang làm gì
à à
ở những cái năng cảm nhận xịn làm sạch
sẽ mô phỏng cho mấy ông nội
mất tiền
khi họ hết bản thử nghiệm rồi bản thử
nghiệm cũng chán
ừ ừ
ở lĩnh Thế mình cho tôi vừa xóa nhầm một
cái rồi lấy cái này đúng
cách Xóa ID
cầm cái hơn
ở đây cái sơ đồ để dễ hình dung thì mình
sẽ có một cái là cái kiểu như này sẽ có
cái phút nhập
em đi ở đây sẽ là kiểu nhập à
Epson ở đây trước được ngay sẽ kêu đây
là
là loại ghế này
khi cài tôi sẽ ra kìa
em lấy ghế giường nằm này
A5 này
a bít lại sao cái thương ạ ạ
thế này mà
lượng ghế
à à
sữa mới với từng có loại ghế
em 2000
Ừ để xem giá xem nhé
À mà thôi mình làm cái cậu ngay không
Không phải Không phải vậy đợi thì được
đi xin lỗi rồi Tôi có bao nhiêu thằng
thì mình sẽ gọi có bao nhiêu thằng loại
ghế thì sẽ có bấy nhiêu hàng hiểu ngay
và kèm là cái số lượng thì hợp lý nhất
cậu vip thì sẽ bao nhiêu cái
copy này
kéo xuống dưới này
à à xe máy
nhiêu cái này nó thế
nhiêu cái ông có bao nhiêu cái loại ghế
ông sẽ chỉ bấy nhiêu cái phút ở đây này
để nhập nhập nhập nhập Đấy sau đó thì nó
sẽ hiển thị ra cái tên là tên là lại
được Nếu giả sử là ông muốn lưu lại cái
sơ đồ ghế giống như ông đang bào thì giả
sử là gia sử xe nào giống xe nào là sẽ
có ba cò ba Cây Vip rồi ba ghế giường
nằm ra xử thế và 10 ghế thừa nè ra sự
thế không ạ Đấy là loại xe đẩy thì nó sẽ
cười nhưng có loại sẽ khác thì chỉ có
giấy ghế rừng nhằm trả lại giống tạo một
cái sơ đồ game mới
ở Vàm sơ đồ về kia thì ông sẽ tên của nó
sẽ khá dài như thế là ba vít 3 nằm ba
thường không ạ Và cái số về thứ hai là
giờ xử là 12 thường ạ sau về thứ ba cái
xử cái tên mà nói thì sẽ dựa đúng những
cái số lượng ghế của nó có sẵn ở trong
cái sơ đồ đấy tự tạo ra thì cái job ai
đấy thì chắc chắn là phải xem lại phải
sửa lại từng nhóm này thì cái đoạn đang
làm như thế này tôi thấy nó hơi trái
nghĩa gì cả Bởi vì nếu hôm nào làm nghe
thấy nhớ cái tên trộm cho bếp điền tên
cái gì cho cái sơ đồ ghế này sơ đồ ghế
nó phải định ra cây chan Cái kiểu hình
ảnh sơ đồ chứ không phải kiểu nhà thứ
hai là ông chọn như này ông chỉ chọn
được cố định 1 loại ghế cho cái xe của
ông nó không đúng lắm ở nhiều xe có kia
rồi
ở giữa xe kết hợp cả hai loại thuế đi
sao không ạ Nhưng cái đoạn này nó không
bị đã bị cậu đang bị cháy nghĩa gì cả
anh em không có ý nghĩa gì nhé
gì đấy Cái Trang Trần Trang để mà sang
quan trọng nhất là cái trang
người dùng thì đâu
I Ever You achieve người dùng đã tìm
chuyến xe
địa điểm đi điểm đến
Ừ Rồi Chuyến Xe
chứ không phải cho ăn lấy giao diện từ
bên nào
ừ ừ
anh trọn vẹn ổn đấy chứ nghèo
ở đó bình tĩnh nha mày Khởi hành này
tuyến xác nhận thông tin khách Tôi thích
kiểu cái kiểu này Cái này gọi khái niệm
Nó là phụ paulist press 3 dạng là kiểu
thành hiểu tiến trình ấy mình đang đến
bước vào bước nào khá hay
nha đam mê trong bệnh viện ông cứ bấm
tiếp tục tiếp tục làm người dùng cảm
thấy khó chịu cả không hiểu bao giờ sắp
được ông làm thế này xuống hiểu là chỉ
còn vài bước nữa tao được giải thoát rồi
cậu thế chả đây
tin
viên trường xe
đó
chị nhỉ Mẹ chị nữa
chị đánh đoạn bên này thì hội ở bên kia
tôi không biết chậm như nào nữa tôi chấm
ở đây nói cho
Hôm nay tôi đang cố chấm hết được cái
nhóm này nhưng vẫn thể có thể không hết
được
anh cho biết rồi xem mình nhóm kia thằng
Anh nó chậm Nhưng mà nhưng mà ở tôi chữa
thể chữa chung của tất cả mấy ông ấy mày
ông có gì cùng Xem rút kinh nghiệm nhé
ạ bây xít
cho mình
à à
a khái niệm
có rồi
ý kiến từ cuối lên á Anh ở đầy sung quá
nha
10 tại do mấy cái nhóm cuối này đôi khi
lại làm cái nhóm Tôi mới tạo ví dụ mấy
cái nhóm này tôi mấy thứ hai chấm Ở Đây
Rồi thức ăn mấy cái nhóm dẫn đầu nhóm
đầu tiên tới Tạo mà nên thành ra là kiểu
ăn phải đăng kiểu bởi vì mấy cái nhóm
này nhóm đầu tiên tạo trước là nó phải
làm ổn trước đúng không ạ
ở gần cuối cập nhật
như chị cập nhật một người à anh ạ
A8
ghét với một bạn khác vậy
Ừ Ok em nhưng mà
ở đâu không cần nhập gì à
yêu ngược Tôi từng bảo cho tới khi mày
ông làm việc cho nhóm hơn cái ông thích
solo bây giờ cũng đang đến đang làm nửa
chừng rồi không thể F1 khác và theo ông
được nhưng mà ông ông phải ông cũng sẽ
buồn đấy nó cũng sẽ kiểu là một mình sẽ
không người đồng hành cùng nó sẽ hiểu
thôi bị khó chịu và bị chậm
à À quên 8 có gì nhỉ
585 tạm chỉ có mỗi email chúng tôi về
Ê mi Ông có cái gì mà ghê
để
cập nhật những phân tích
cách chữa
ông solo Nhưng mà nếu không phải solo
đây để làm được nghe không phải số lô ở
đây chán bỏ rồi nghĩ là mình không có
trách nhiệm phụ trách nhiệm với ông nhé
lỗi chưa
đợi xem đợi thì đổi tí chờ đợi tôi một
tí
có thể xóa bạn nhỏ 12 vậy
à à
thơ Nguyễn Thi xong
Anh ở thì tôi tôi nó lại đây tôi biết
được đã làm xong cái gì Còn thiếu cái gì
thôi à
Cho tôi xem giá để xem nha
phim hoạt hình
từ khóa
xin code
để tạo áp date of shipment
cách tạo database
ta có
chị
xem phim thử Xóa rồi nghe giao diện mà
Tôi thấy rõ ràng ông ấy đang làm giao
diện
em có tí có tí kodi không
bảo mày làm mới giao diện nhé
ừ ừ
kiểm tra lạ
không không làm cái đồ này thôi lớp của
nữa nhé
Ê
mày về có bạn chưa có cái gì cả
ở nhóm 14
ừ ừ
bảo vệ loa
Hi Hi tạm bảo vệ đời sau em ạ
ờ ờ
rất chăm bí mật ảo tạo ra tay
em vẫn chưa có cái đấy móp nhóm của mình
Ok Ok Ok
em nha à
Ừ rồi cho đi
a booking
cài đặt sân
cho họ tên số điện thoại thời gian nhận
được gần trả
em Email điện Chi
anh không cần địa chỉ không Em thì chỉ
đến chán em ghét tìm thấy nhà đánh
anh có một tình kia mấy nhỉ kiếm như mới
ra ra được cái sân các hư nữa rồi nó đặt
ạ
ừ ừ
chị sẽ ra à à Chỗ Chris này ngon Nó đi
lên hai cái gì đó đúng
giống kiểu làm nó hiện rồi
Xin chào bạn chúc lại thế nó hơi bị
ngược rõ ràng bảo làm cái làm cái móc áp
này trước rồi mới làm nó diện Em béo hãy
rõ là làm nó diện rồi mấy ông bị chụp
mẫu áp thì nó bị sai rồi mà bản chất
nóng hoặc vì rõ là mọi ắp này tôi bây
giờ tôi bảo yêu cầu sửa thì mấy ông ngồi
sửa đấy đi nếu như sữa cốc rồi mong chụp
lại phát nữa
nghe vô lý không Nếu không sẽ vẽ chán
chê cái mẫu áp đã cho nó xong đã rồi mấy
ông ấy tập trung vào ngồi cốt
bây giờ mày ông Năm là bị ngược đúng
cô đơn giản khu vực bỏ quay
Ừ nếu đang làm đi trang thế á thấy thế
này tôi bảo mình không làm sao đu xích
rồi
Anh tên sân giá ảnh
ở khu vực lại sân loại Xuân mã sân có
kiểu đây
thể tích được hết thì nó cứ chết
Nhóm em nhóm nào nhé
nãy tôi vẽ đây
ờ ờ đi xa
ừ ừ
Để trung hòa cải tạo sân này thì ra cái
gì ạ
thấy mấy ông vẫn đã bị ngược vào chưa
hình dung được bài toán nhà ông đang vẫn
nghĩ là tôi chỉ đơn giản chỉ cho bé về
mỗi phone thêm sửa xóa là nhiều thế là
sai bản chất ở đây đó là về ông sẽ cần
phải hiển thị ra cái trang Index đầu
tiên đã cái Trang nhìn thị tất cả trông
nó sẽ giao diện như nào là khi bấm vào
cái nút
thì nó sẽ như thế nào Ví dụ Giả sử dụng
cho hợp này nhá bên admin nó sẽ quản lý
nó là gì ông để khu vực lên trên cùng là
một trong những cái sai rồi nó Hoàng như
thế cái mình quan tâm ở đây mình sẽ quan
tâm là cái lịch đặt hay các thứ thứ đấy
Thế nếu tôm yêu cầu mà ông phải mua vé
lại cả menu nữa vì bé ông còn chưa biết
được sự tính năng nào thì nhanh thường
thường xuyên người lượng dùng này cái
thứ nhất với ai là khi mà bấm vào menu
lại bản chất Nó sẽ hiển thị ra cái trang
như thế nào đấy cái cái cái ở đây Hình
dung và bài toán khá là người dùng sẽ
bấm vào cái đầu tiên được dùng vào cho
người dùng sẽ bấm vào cái trộn Chọn khu
vực trở nặng hiển thị a Xem theo khu vực
đó bấm vào sẽ rửa ta đã sân khu vực đấy
hôm sau đó thì mới có có lấy nút để phải
thêm sân mà khu vực này ngay tưởng như
thế về thêm nhiều sân cùng vào khu vực
đấy là gì gió Ngang tại chứ không phải
là kiểu hiển thị ra đầy đủ for thêm thử
Xóa nha Tôi không cần không cần thế này
cái này tôi không cần cái này cái phone
này giống hết cái đồ ăn bột nó khác gì
đâu mà thằng này như thế ông đang làm là
ông đang bắt chước đồ ăn một cái cũng
làm được không ạ Còn làm đồ ăn hay thì
rõ ra là ngay từ cái form hiển thị cái
file thời trang đến đất Thời Trang mới
vào trang hiển thị nó phải trông như thế
nào Sau đó thì bấm các nút như thế nào
để cho tiện cho người dùng những người
dùng dễ hiểu cái phần mềm của ông đúng
không ạ Chứ không phải mày cái con thêm
thử Xóa như này em có nên sợ sáng ngày
tôi yêu cầu mới ông vẽ làm gì với ông sẽ
thấy mấy ông vẽ cái này chả tác dụng gì
không khác gì Đồ ăn bột đúng ạ tôi không
yêu cầu mà ông ấy vẽ lại cái này thì
chồng đưa một đâu
anh đúng không nó hiểu cho
À hôm trước tôi ngồi vẽ và méo một cái
ví dụ rồi đấy ông ạ Và tôi chưa vẽ em bé
ông về cái ví dụ Index các thứ thôi cái
Trang đi Đấy trong hình chị nha thôi
nhưng mà đến xanh bên đến amin thì ra nó
có thể giống nhau là nhìn thị trong bảng
nhưng mà có phải có một vài tính năng
thì nó không thể hiển thị trong bạc được
nói đi cổ khác cũng như là bên khách
hàng thì nó không hiển thị dạng bản được
đấy phải những dạng những kiểu khác Nếu
không gửi cho chúng không phải vẽ những
thứ đấy giống như vừa nãy thì có cái
nhóm vừa nãy để mặt cái bật Đăng ký lớp
học Chẳng hạn khi ra trong cũng gọi là
trong nó không bị dị dạng bạc ấy thì cậu
khai trong nó dễ hình dung ông ạ ở ngã
mẹ không quan trọng nhất để những tin
nhắn quan trọng đấy Hỏi tính năng thêm
sữa xóa Nếu làm đầy đủ tính lên thì mày
Xóa tra rất là bìa
mọi
người Tôi không nhớ về nhóm vừa nãy là
nhóm nào rồi Hiện đại khái là như thế nó
vậy hiểu tôi đấy
à à
U16 vừa rồi ah
A gọi cũng có rồi em à à đâu rồi để xem
lại lần này bắt đấy đặt có Mỹ là bếp cho
không phải mùi đoán nó là gì
không cần phải giao diện cảm cả của một
cái Trang mà
đứng yên là có một cái trang tổng quát
và trong trang hiệu trang iCloud Ví dụ ở
Hàm cái lao cái nào admin này để mà Ông
ngồi vẽ luôn cả menu có thử và và cái
logo như để ở đâu và kiểu cái phút ba ạ
À cái footer 2 cái hết đô này như thế
nào đấy em một cái trang live watch được
chưa ạ đấy thì
tiết lộ trang Index của bên gì gì đó thì
nên chỉ thị trong như nào nút nên để như
thế nào thời tiếp theo và luôn đấy nó cứ
dần dần dần
nghĩa là làm không làm bán hàng làm
trang tin tức thế anh anh nhất Ông vừa
kịp sửa nữa trông làm xong ông chưa kịp
Facebook thì nó đóng lỗi đấy không ạ
Cũng làm hai tháng bây giờ không kịp thì
ông cứ làm trang tin tức thôi cháu đơn
giản hiển thị Xem xem thử Xóa ở bên
emminh số đó thì bên khách hàng chỉ cần
hiển thị đúng gái mình vừa thêm đấy
thành công rồi nhanh gọn nhẹ nhõm
ờ ờ
Lê Đức Đức
ra ngắm lên đùi tỏi
17 rồi
bài hát Ai cho em lắm
Ừ ngủ đi
à à
chỉ có hai người mà nghỉ tại sao có mỗi
một bạn đang quét nhà
từ lâu rồi
à à
Ừ ông kia
có gì phải học ngôn ngữ bác em chứ t có
thứ chứ ạ và phải biết về đã tàu bay
có gì chấm mà
U16 thì có nhưng mà về cơ bản thì phải
sửa lại Nó không ạ thì sửa lại
chị sẽ tạm để sống rồi đó chấm nữa nhưng
nhóm mày xem mày cứ nghiệp phải sửa lại
cái mô phỏng mô phỏng nhé
anh hứa update sinh đôi nghệ sĩ này
giao diện đúng không
Và đang tập đây
xem thử xem thử nha
a a a
có ai đó phải đọc
ạ bây giờ cái Ngó Hôm trước mình chấm
rồi
các em ạ
chưa ạ
nói về vụ này rồi
Ừ ông để cho hiển thị xem được gì chứ
cùng ạ
à À ông em trước cầm ra lại
Ê mày chưa Tâm nhân ái tôi chồng uống
trước rồi Thế thôi
Ừ anh xuống vào nhóm này cũng tương đối
ơi cũng thương đó cậu đã tập bay và tài
liệu rồi
Ừ nhưng mà tài liệu rồi cẩn cũng phải
sửa là một tí không cho tôi góp ý rồi
à à
ở giao diện tính năng
à À đây rồi khom Đặt lịch hẹn nhưng cũng
từ hôm trước rồi ở nhóm mình hôm trước
anh cũng chấm rồi ok
anh cũng có đặt tay vào tài liệu 521
Anh cũng mới dân đề cũng chưa cập nhật
thêm gì cả đúng không
anh alo mùng 10 Đợi tí tôi nhầm đấy Tôi
bị nhầm sang bây giờ sao thẳng sang khám
rồi hôm mùng 10 là cũng mới gần đây mà
Ừ Thôi nhưng mà nhóm mày cầm chai rượu
Ừ mùng 5 xem nhé đợi xem nhé
A5
khi tôi chấm được tuần trước
Anh ở nhóm mày sẽ vẫn chưa cập nhật thêm
nữa
Ừ mùng 10 10 cập nhật
em nằm ở cũ rồi
họ đậu xanh đặc trưng
à à
ở nhóm 22
em
đặt cái tên quen cao nhất ở đấy ạ Ok em
chú ý
Xin chào Có gì cả đậu xanh
52 mất tích rồi
Ừ ok
à à
cách chữa về cái à
I Swear
Ừ rồi
a cho tôi sẽ bàn nào mày sao tôi sẽ nhắn
tin nhau nói riêng sao
các bạn cho chống đấy à
Ai Cập nhật hôm nay luôn
Cho xem ảnh có tài liệu có đủ chưa
ừ ừ
đang đọc
em chưa chưa có giao chưa có gì cả
CRD thôi
Tôi muốn xem Shadow Dash
chị đã có gì đâu không
à à
tài liệu
25 24
này
nhanh nhỉ
tình trạng
Mỹ Tâm Trạng
ừ ừ
Em
thích chưa được tạo ra thế xe
I say
Anh tên hãng số chỗ ngồi
ở trạng thái 13 số xe biển số giá xe là
thuê
ở nhóm này về cái gì nhé
à à
em à Cho thuê xe vậy Cho tôi xem
à mình tưởng cái này liên quan đến
thương vụ
kiểu
đặt vé xe khách mà gần ngay
nữ diễn viên
mọi người bỏ qua không có ta
cách xác minh tài khoản Việt à
à à
minh tài khoản nhỉ nó đến tận nơi phải
duyệt qua chứ nhỉ
Ừ cho qua mạng này nó lấy sự ảnh trên
mạng được mà
nhầm đấy có đại biểu nhầm đấy Đó là ông
ngồi ở đoạn này mình tự xoạc xoạc hợp
đồng đấy mình sẽ có nút đó soạn hợp đồng
ra cái gì đó nói mình mới kiểu xác nhận
cái thứ thứ rồi in ra ấy
cho mọi người này đến tận nơi để mà làm
việc ông ạ Chứ không phải làm có online
ngay đâu Tự nhiên mình cũng có nhật
thông tin các thứ thứ cùng của khách
hàng thôi
à Anh nhầm rồi
ông thuê xe qua mạ nữa nó sẽ ship cho em
tận nhà không ạ
Chị linh tinh không mà không online đâu
nhân dân thì
về cơ bản thằng ấy vẫn ở đến lấy xe đúng
không ạ Cũng thấy thế thì không quan tâm
này mình rồi đấy
tiếng quạt nghỉ dùng laptop rồi ra
laptop tôi cũng chạy được cũng nóng số
điện thoại tốt phải cắm quạt tản nhiệt
và Mic của tôi nó kiểu lọc được tiền
không có nghe mấy thôi
ừ ừ
không
đi tìm kiếm tình trạng thái mới giờ cũ
ngày chả số chỗ ô tô đúng không Này ô tô
đúng không sợ một số chỗ ở đây này
ở chung
Cô Hoa ơi ô tô
Ê mày thứ đơn giản này
qua mạng nhanh như thế đâu Không không
Chơi kiểu đấy được không
đã xác minh danh tính không Không chơi
cái này được nhá
à à
về làm thủ tục các thơ Tớ ở ngay trực
tiếp không anh cũng thấy được
khi sex
quên xem lại có đã tới bay chưa
Ừ ok
có 525
ở phòng rồi
ý sức khỏe
à à có gì đấy
anh không thế này làm sao so được
em đặt lịch khám
khi chọn bác sĩ ở ngay đá không phải bịa
ra cái phần chọn bác sĩ các thứ các thứ
chọn trường khoa các kiểu xử đã rồi khi
bấm vào ấn đặt lịch Chỉ hiển thị thông
tin để mà nhập cá thù thôi chứ không
phải kiểu chọn kiểu kiểu như thế này
ở đầu tiên thì phải hiển thị ra từ trận
chứng Khoa này rồi một loạt các bác sĩ
này nhìn bác sỹ chống vệ uy tín em ạ gì
đấy Xong rồi máy Ấn các thứ chứ chứ
em chẳng hạn thế không ạ Ông Hiển thị
kiểu này thứ khó có áp cho từng dùng có
gì thì cả ngay người dùng kiểu Nhìn cái
này chẳng biết được bác sĩ nào bác sĩ
nào thật nên này cái vụ chọn bác sĩ như
này nó trái nghĩa gì cả thật không hiểu
do thừa chọn ngày cái đầu tiên là tự
động bác sĩ nào trống thì lập tự động
lắp và kiểu thế Chúng nó ngay thì như
nhóm Mày mới là chẳng có gì cả nó nó có
nhau mà
ở tạm tôi sẽ tạm dừng sau nhé ngắm 26
Ê mày nhó mày nhớ mày nhóm 26 27 nhiêu
tuổi mới tạo nên thì Nga cũng chưa làm
cái gì vậy
A8 tôi sẽ chấm sao
a28 có rồi à
e27 có làm rồi ok tưởng cho làm gì đó
sao
à à
xe nâng ôtô chở ra đi người ta điệu đấy
Ừ ông là con nít Okay đây sai
anh dậy ông ghi con biết là ok đấy hả
anh em có cái gì chấm chấm cốc à thưởng
có thợ thêm một cá mở lên nhé
Ừ
công việc con cái này nó nha linh tinh
tôi dậy thầy thấy em tại thế
ê ê
xe Open có thư viện à hay nghỉ
sản xuất xịn anh em à
Ừ nhưng mà tôi không thích kiểu làm giao
diện ở bên controller
anh nhìn chồng hơi lạ
ở chùa dâu nữa cơ à Làm cái gì tự nhiên
có rô này sự phân quyền bình thường rồi
Không
restroom made đ
dù gì cũng chỉ có sẵn theo chìa khóa
thôi Có cái gì không sport sport luôn Ừ
thế Tại sao phải thêm cái đoạn này ghi
là sau khi có lại trong con thích nha
có ai làm này mất công ơi không biết sửa
Chồng tao thích à
với công thức này sẽ có cái ở đây hay
này
ở đâu
anh
ăn tô này Đấy trình và tham vọng này
xe tải xuống phải là ông ngồi sửa sửa
chai những ai đâu nhưng từ sau cứ mỗi
lần ông đầy cái Android sau này à
a
certain export trị sản xuất toàn bộ danh
sách tất cả sinh viên á Không thường nó
sẽ post cụ thể post theo khóa theo lớp
thì đó nó quý hơn và export và cái khó ở
đây không phải có cho vui rồi nhé Ai tên
cột nó sẽ bị khó hiểu ông sẽ phải sửa cả
tên cột nữa cũng phải ghi tên con theo
kiểu là tìm Việt có dấu đấy là một
trường hợp ngoại nhiều cái hình kiểu nữa
Ừ Ông làm cái này cho có rồi
Ừ Thế mày có mày chả tác dụng huyện nói
thật
ừ ừ
xong được xe Audi từng đối nhưng mà
không hề có về mô phỏng diện thì tôi
chưa biết được rồi ông sẽ làm cụ thể
trong nhà chạy cốt thử để mua
25 26
Anh vừa gọi nhóm 276 nha 7 đúng không ạ
I said I
anh còn chưa kịp viết thông tin với ông
trong ngày thôi không inbox tôi mệt cái
thông tin ở đây tôi cập nhật với sau tôi
còn nào
xe tay ga bây giờ tới mấy thông tin này
mày ông cũng tự chủ động liên hệt nhau
thì ok tôn trọng ừ
25 26
ở
đây Fit Me
thấm giúp em về đâu tơi
ô tô màu gì
ở Vegas của Brazil
ô kê
I love and parts for PC
anh vào ngày
a
Kamen Rider
em về level 9
ở lại
ở những cái này bay đồ cơ ở đây
khi khai báo thấy ghê cái
tên bác như sau để đấy đúng
ừ ừ
chưa rõ Nói cái gì đó
a web design
Ừ Mấy chị có cái này nói gì cả ở đâu em
mấy ông dốc của Bảo chấm là gì
trong đó
ờ ờ
như bạn chất thì đúng là nó sẽ không thể
quay lại các thử thế nhưng mà
Ừ cái này Thực ra là để bác em xử lý các
thứ thế thế thôi Thực tế là mình cần làm
cả khán em nữa thì nếu mà về sau ông làm
dự án ở ngoài ví dụ thằng view hay là
thằng mấy hàng khác Facebook của Speed
thì nó sẽ bắt ở fernand nữa ta kiểu khi
mà khi mà nó sẽ luôn gọn lên điểm kiểm
tra quyền cái thứ thứ sau phần làm điều
đấy rồi bác em không cần là loạn đó xúc
tại lô tô như thế này bác em về sau chủ
yếu làm về mỗi kỳ ai trả về kết quả thôi
nhà ông không cần bận tâm người quá đâu
ừ ừ
trong khi đó trong cái trang web của ông
đâu có quan trọng gì vấn đề đấy ngoại
tìm hiểu tìm hiểu vẫn được không ra làm
như ý thôi à
anh nghe ngoài tập trung làm cái tính
năng tính năng quan trọng đi làm thế tập
trung vào những cái đầu nó trả lời phê
vấn đề gì
anh cũng ngồi cập nhật remix ok
ô hay sao lại có gì
à à
Ừ ok
e56 có gì rồi
I asked Me Ok
Ừ anh đi có gì ở đây
và đặc biệt
ạ bây giờ
em nói chuyện CRD đúng không
à à
không alo
chị xem nhà với chồng nha
phải quan trọng này tạm thời bỏ qua chưa
làm
Em nói sao
Em làm trước phần nền
cho thuê có một tí gì bánh em lắm
e-teacher
ở đây ok
anh từng đấy đúng
ê ê
vẫn thiếu nhiều ngoạn
nhóm ra buổi hôm nay thì mới Ông thấy
chấm Có nhóm thì làm tương đối ổn rồi có
nhóm thì chưa biết gì đang bị mất liên
lạc thứ tôi sẽ phải chủ động liên lạc
với nhau mới sau A
a favorite làm sao nick Facebook rồi
Vì sao con chó lớn nhà
nghèo vĩ đại
Hạn chế dùng cho thôi nên dùng à đây
ship cho thằng level cho nó mạnh còn nếu
mà ông muốn tung cho cô để về sau nó
giảm thiểu
chỉ dẫn hay gì đó Nói chung cho nó sẽ có
đúng trong vài trường hợp nó cũng sai
nhưng mà hạn chỉ giống chó thôi
vì vậy xin chip của nó thì cái sau sữa
Cốt nó cũng dễ con voi Bây giờ ông về
sau sẽ cố tình sẽ khó à
mô Ai Cũng Có ảnh không
đang
làm gì đấy
A2 chấm 16.1 là cái gì hả
Anh chưa hiểu một cái lắm
ở Facebook Jo kiểu dáng cực Bảnh không
ông
Ừ ông làm xong các diện Ông chụp màn
hình
chỉ cần này à nó sẽ phải là nó thể theo
bạn cửa nhà nhưng mà
Yên lên bố trí được hả
Anh không biết là đặt kiểu gì luôn
e ko
khi hết pin
anh em biết ông này đã tên là gì Em nói
gì à
Em lo đi
Ừ cái trang hiển thị tổng quát của tôi
lấy là tôi chưa thấy cái Trang nhìn thì
tổng quát nó ở đâu Sao không phải
e-news
thử sáng Điên à Đi Sống
cho Android clip
1000 cái này em nói lý sợ đây nó sẽ phải
có phải có cái chọn chọn các phòng ban
nó cũng bàn nào nữa số đó đến mấy thì ra
cái danh sách nhân viên này
chị sẽ xóa cột trong bar này đi nó sẽ ở
trên thông tin cá nhân chi tiết thì nó
sẽ ở cụ khác nhưng mà ông muốn đề mấy
cái thông tin mới thông tin này à
Ừ cái này lần trước in quá à
ông thể buôn màu đỏ Nếu mà sự trên sớm
hay muộn gì đó
ăn gì thế
em không cần quan tâm một cái đấy Cái
quan trọng là kiểu để cái listen thì ra
là khi mà thêm nhân viên vào thì sẽ như
thế nào của Vân những cái đấy những cái
quan trọng vì ông sẽ quan tâm mình đấy
Ừ cái này đều đều giống nhau rồi không ạ
vì thế ông hoàn toàn này góp Trung lại
cái đấy sau A
Nghe kể chuyện hình chỗ nào hiển thị cơ
bản Cường anh cũng được cũng được
nhật cả mình cái cốt cùng với Thôi chú
rồi xem nhé
rồi thì không biết xưa tôi nghe nó sửa
ông ấy mệt đấy à ừ ừ
trường mà mình sẽ chọn à
được không cần mất công phải do ngay đêm
mà cốt để so sánh rồi nha
đấy
vụ khoe hát kết hợp được ít thì bạn ạ
a ph
xe buýt
nhưng mà không nhớ để tao chín thì tao
tán nữa xem nhé
ở gần đây xem tài liệu mới nhất nó lâu
nhỉ
à à
xem trên a telegram có đợi tí thôi thử
mở t RAM của tôi lên xem
bí
ngô mới gần đây rồi nó có cái vụ đấy
nhưng mà tôi chưa Xem được rồi phiên bản
nó sẽ bạn nào thôi Hay phết kết hợp mãi
thì nó mới làm vụ cậu bé hát cái vỏ quýt
đấy
à Cháu à là cốt kiểu như thế trong lòng
anh thôi chứ nó không cũng không khác
biệt lắm
Em nhận được tính nhau tí nhé
à à
thì kệ họ
ý nghĩa nó Sẽ cậu bình thường mà ông sẽ
kiểu que hát tất cả cái đi thằng ship
đấy nó sẽ thêm mình cái điều kiện ngay
đúng không ngờ ông lại phải mất công
thêm ít nữa để mà ông sẽ cậu lấy thêm
cái ship đấy kết hợp với đúng những điều
kiện như thế chứ là nó sẽ rất đắt hơn là
Wave cảng là xong rồi nhanh của nó nhưng
mà cái này là cho
Ừ tao chín rồi nó nhỉ
thứ 8.com nhé
bộ này mà rõ ràng đã vẽ nên làm được đấy
từ từ lâu rồi không được nhưng mà tội
không để ý lắm
à à
làm theo Christmas thay vì cứ cho ra
ngoài như này à
Có gì tôi sẽ xem cụ thể mấy ông Khi mà
ông để mô sau
à à
3dp hiển nhiên là có ck đề xuất sẵn có D
không thể bỏ qua được
Ok Gọi Mai chấm Cũng tương đồng như thế
cũng khá dài
Em xem mấy ông có gọi được mà
sau nhé cho bộ hôm nay tạm ấy Thế đã tội
chậm lúc một vài nhóm mày không thấy em
vào nhóm chiến đấu như thế rồi mà nhóm
thì đó
anh ra không quan tâm nhóm khác như thế
nào Mình chỉ quan tâm việc
chọn dạng là mình rút kinh nghiệm từ
những nhóm khác chứ nhóm khác mà đang
kiểu rất là tốt hãy đang rất là tệ chứ
không phải mình so sánh mình hơn người
em mình kém người ta không ạ tự mình làm
tự mình phấn đấu mình mình sau sàng 10
chính bản thân mình có khứ ở cái bộ hơn
thôi không ạ Cũng chưa rồi đánh giá mấy
ông mà nhóm này rồi ngắm kĩ là bao giờ
cả Không ạ Chắc chắn là cuộc sống ai
cũng lương đều như ai thì nó chẳng có gì
thú vị không ạ
mà quan trọng là mình sẽ hiểu phấn đấu
mình hơn bản thân mình là tốt rồi không
ạ gì chưa
Ừ hồi bữa mày cho tạm kết thúc rồi Có gì
thì
Ờ có gì để có gì tôi sẽ mày Ông cứ hỏi
inbox trên discord là tốt nhất các tôi ở
trong cái nhóm của mấy ông để tôi sẽ trả
lời trong nhóm đấy Cho tôi dễ nhớ cứ
inbox riêng đôi khi tôi cũng quên mất sư
ông nào nhóm nào nói thật như thế chỗ là
mày không phải quen nó việc tóc phòng
làm việc kiểu như thế nghĩa kênh nào ở
kênh kênh nào ở kênh nha
trao đổi cái gì đó Ngoại nên trao đổi ở
đâu và vật nó gửi cho em đấy
ở tạm bợ Mày cứ luôn nha cho béo nhé
à à